[Música]
ya llegó el momento para hablar de
economía aquí en France 24 para ello ya
contamos en nuestro estudio con Juan
Pablo lucum y Juan Pablo bienvenido hoy
vamos a dedicar esta sección a la
economía de Estados Unidos y más en
concreto a las grandes empresas y el
rendimiento que tuvieron durante el
pasado trimestre Así es Rodrigo buenas
noches y hablamos de este tema porque
los resultados de Grandes minoristas
como Target fueron en general negativos
sus ganancias no estuvieron a la altura
de lo que esperaban las ganancias de la
minorista de Mineápolis cayeron un 52%
en el tercer trimestre de este año una
cifra bastante alta y que hizo a su vez
que las acciones de la compañía también
estuvieran en números rojos en varias
ocasiones la elevada inflación presionó
el bolsillo de los estadounidenses y es
esto pues empezaron a recortar sus
compras o a comprarlo estrictamente
necesario esto a su vez obligó a las
grandes superficies a reducir los
precios de sus productos y por ello
estas ganancias que estamos viendo hoy y
precisamente eso fue lo que nos explicó
previamente Alberto Bernal León
investment desde Nueva York Estados
Unidos
yo creo que lo que estamos viendo de los
resultados de estas grandes cadenas en
Estados Unidos es bastante lógico A qué
voy con este comentario que acabo de
hacer que es que realmente estamos
viviendo todavía un escenario global que
que ninguno de nosotros jamás hubiese
pensado que fuese a ocurrir porque
ninguno de nosotros había vivido una
pandemia Entonces qué pasó durante la
pandemia la verdad es que durante la
pandemia las familias en Estados Unidos
utilizaron esa oportunidad para para
adelantar compras de bienes durables que
normalmente no hubiesen hecho se
compraron muchos electrónicos muchas
televisiones nuevos muebles nuevas cosas
para las casas etcétera Pues porque la
gente no gastado en restaurantes y en
viajes entonces tenía más dinero para
gastar en bienes durables y lo que
estamos viendo en este momento es Pues
básicamente el guayabo atado a ese
exceso de demanda que se vio durante la
pandemia y es completamente normal que
estemos bien en estos momentos menores
menor demanda por por estos productos
porque pues la verdad es que si uno ya
se compró un televisor hace dos años
pues no se compra un televisor nuevo en
este momento eso es realmente lo que lo
que lo que están mostrando estos
resultados Juan Pablo y es que la
principal Economía del mundo no se ha
salvado de otro problema global que es
la inflación que ha afectado
prácticamente a todas las economías
completamente no se salva y de hecho se
ha visto profundamente afectada en 2022
la tasa inflacionaria Fue bastante alta
sin embargo en octubre el panorama
mejoró considerablemente pues pasó del
8,2% interanual de septiembre al 7,7
anual de octubre una cifra que no se
había visto en décadas en el informe del
gobierno se presentaron los servicios o
productos que más aumentaron que en este
momento los estamos viendo a este
panorama se le sumó el fenómeno llamado
la gran renuncia que sucedió pues este
año en el que había exceso de vacantes y
muy pocas personas dispuestas a trabajar
entonces se unirán las grandes empresas
a los despidos masivos que ya han hecho
las tecnológicas como Amazon Twitter y
meta esto no respondió Nosotros sí
pensamos que va a haber algo de
disminución en la cantidad de empleo en
Estados Unidos pero esta recesión en
Estados Unidos va a ser una recesión
única desde el punto de vista histórico
porque el incremento del en el desempleo
que se va a ver en Estados Unidos
durante esta recesión que se nos viene
va a ser mucho menor a lo que hubiese
sido en cualquier otro momento histórico
A qué voy en Estados Unidos todavía hay
más o menos los 10 millones de opciones
de empleo abiertas déjame repetir eso 10
millones de opciones de empleo abiertas
que no consiguen gente para trabajar
Entonces yo creo que se van a disminuir
esas opciones las empresas están
quitando ofertas de de empleo hay otras
que están despidiendo pero creo que
comenzamos desde un nivel de extremo
nivel de empleabilidad por lo tanto esa
disminución de empleo va a generar
obviamente
en algunos casos en algunas familias
Pero va a ser diferente por ejemplo lo
que se vio en durante la pandemia o lo
que se vio durante la crisis del 2008 y
Juan Pablo definitivamente este panorama
de vacantes laborales del que estamos
hablando debe empeorar mucho no la
situación económica del país y
profundicemos precisamente en este tema
porque revisamos los datos más recientes
y pues la tasa de desempleo se ubicó en
3,7% en octubre Pero entonces si hay
vacantes disponibles y personas
desempleadas en el país Por qué no toman
estos trabajos esto también le
preguntamos al analista Pues es que eso
es una de las cosas que todos los
economistas que que seguimos la historia
de Estados Unidos nos preguntamos en
este momento
el 22% de los jóvenes en Estados Unidos
entre 18 y 24 años no están ni
estudiando ni trabajando
tú me preguntas a mí qué me está pasando
con esas personas y mi respuesta es no
tengo ni la menor idea Yo no sé qué
están haciendo esas personas no sé si
están jugando Xbox si están viendo
Netflix si están trayendo criptomonedas
no tengo ni la menor idea que están
haciendo esas personas Pero como
analista lo único que yo puedo
pronosticar y pensar es que esas
personas eventualmente se van a quedar
sin dinero y van a tener que volver a la
fuerza laboral por lo tanto en los
próximos años trimestres pensaría yo que
esas personas que no están trabajando en
este momento se vean obligadas a volver
a la fuerza laboral porque literalmente
se quedaron sin dinero pues Juan Pablo
Muchas gracias por este repaso económico
Seguiremos muy atentos a esta situación
económica de Estados Unidos